For a third day, wildfires sweeping
through parts of Los Angeles, lock
after block, there is nothing
but ash.
Breaking news where U.S.
President Donald Trump assigned
tariffs on America's top trading
partners.
The supply chains will have a
profound impact on inflation.
On the well-being of your
households.
We are seeing very significant
demand for maven, both
in and outside of America.
Tonight I can report to the world
that the strikes were a spectacular
military success.
More than a summer's worth of rain
fell in a matter of hours,
triggering unprecedented flash
flooding.
After Russia launched another major
overnight attack.
On that country's energy
infrastructure.
China's largest military
display.
Here showcase a
power.
The government shutdown stretches
into a fresh new week.
And the path forward is unclear.
Sound the alarm that Silicon
Valley and the West have lost
their way.
You're in favor of this world order,
what have you built that works?
We are in a software defined world
and the nation that leads software
is the USA.
Please welcome co-founder
and chief executive officer at
Palantir, Dr. Alex
Karp.
Well, I always
realized I'd be accused of
something, but this is
a flashing light.
Well, delayed to be here, delayed to
have you here, I
delayed to be in
New York where I was born, great
city.
And.
Yeah, we are
mercilessly and proudly patriotic.
That's obvious.
But I think one of the things that
is often implicit
in why we've been in our
success and that we really came to
see as a huge advantage when we
moved into commercial,
primarily US commercial, was
when we went to
the government in the beginning,
it was the FBI.
The CIA and
ended up being special operations
command that we
had this very very naive idea
that Because
we were patriotic.
We would just build things that
work where we would absorb
the value creation
responsibility meaning the risk that
we would provide more value for
These incredibly special people
than what they could pay
us
That germ of an idea.
Is actually probably the single
most radical thing we ever did.
It went from PG,
which is the Intel product.
Actually, the architecture
of that product,
the security model, and
our interactions with NLP
technology,
really years later gave us insights
that were really important
for building
ontology, actually the original
ontology precursor.
It was patented, I think,
by Bob McGrew and Aki Jane,
two very famous technologists.
One at Palantir, one went on
to be a very important
early researcher
at OpenAI.
And then we
built a number of other products,
Gaia for the Special Operations
Command. And so the products that
powered those news stories,
Maven, which has
changed the battlefield.
And then later in commercial
foundry, which many of you use,
ontology, AIP, the idea
that you would need orchestration
to make large language models
valuable.
So how do you build value,
not just have a AI market?
How do you work downstream of that?
FDEs, as opposed to just handing you
the product.
And the way I think that
Palantir is divergent
from software
Silicon Valley companies.
Is that because
we absorbed the value, and because
actually we thought, obviously
it's kind of obvious, but because we
thought and knew the soldiers
who were going to battle
were more important than we
were, which at
the time did not take much, but
I mean morally,
we built products in a
whole culture, FDE, internal
orchestration, how we prioritize
things. How we learn about your
specific use cases, how we
really never try to
become the expert or become your
business.
We want, we want, literally do
want your business to be the
specific, enhance the specificity
of it, make it the very best
business in the world.
We do not want you to be a
commodity. We're not trying to, all
these things that,
we built something that's quite
radical. That's just not how Silicon
Valley companies actually work.
The job of a Silicon Valley software
company is to take your
revenue, its multiple,
transfer it into their company and
get a higher multiple, and buy you
a steak dinner.
That's the job.
This is why analysts didn't like us.
We couldn't get bankers to underrate
Palantir.
I mean, part of the reason why I
wanted to do a DPO is because
instead of handing huge
amounts of money or as
retail investors, meaning people
investing their own money, call
attendees.
To bankers, I wanted to make sure
that normal people participated.
But it was also, bankers were like,
wait a minute, you're selling a
product where there's no
automatic, the only lock-in is that
you're gonna create more value
tomorrow than you did today and
that you are gonna get paid
downstream of value
and there's not Salesforce paying
for golf and steak dinners
and the people we met that even
tried to do that are unpleasant.
They were like.
That you're not gonna make any money
and we sure as hell aren't gonna
make money.
And those people,
and honestly, they still hate us.
I can't find a banker that likes me.
I'm like, could you look at my bank
account? Take a meeting with me,
please.
None of them will meet with me even
today.
It's like, I'm not,
this is not hyperbolic.
You would think I'd be able to talk
to any banker now.
They're like, the door's closed
everywhere. But because
of
those early moments, the formative
moment of we must
create value for these people
who are risking their lives.
And it has to be productized
to the point where you can use
it in Afghanistan,
in Iraq.
We built this culture of,
you know, we're non parasitic
relationship.
We, I really
value those people.
And I hope that what
you sense in our partnerships with
you is that we actually
really are with Ontology,
Foundry, AIP,
and our FDs,
we are aspiring
to lift you
and that we only
actually get rewarded over
time where your business
thrives.
And by the way, this just makes
being at Palantir a lot more fun,
because for all the crazy things
we do, and we do crazy things,
we blew up a
massive, massive deployment
in the US government because a
general asked me to talk
to somebody, I probably shouldn't
have ever done this, I was like, hey,
I want to talk to your FDs about
some of my great ideas, and
of course the people are like,
no, that idea is stupid, but you
don't have, you're not smart enough
to know how stupid it is.
So that set us back years.
You can accuse us of a lot of
things. The thing about Palantir
though, is we really are actually
trying to supply
software and LLM management
in the form of ontology
that makes your business better.
And that is a really cool thing
because you will over time
grow to like us.
And it's just much more fun
on the inside.
And so that's the fact that this
is working like.
At a massive level of
scale is actually even surprising to
us.
I would say we have many of the
leaders of Palantir here.
I don't think any of us thought it
could work this well.
So, and so,
yeah, you know, I hope you have a
great time.
You know, the other last as a final
note, the very confusing
thing about this revolution
is because the value is
not in being a commodity, really
the people who select and figure
out a way to do it correctly are
just going to do much better than
the people who don't
exert agency.
And so the mere fact that we're
finding ways to work together.
And it's also country specific.
I spent half my life in Germany, and
no one's interested in this stuff in
Germany right now. That's a huge
problem.
So with that, happy times.
Very happy, I'm glad you delayed you
came here, and pretty cool place to
have a get-together and.
Please welcome Chief Investment
Officer at Healthpeak,
Adam Mabry.
Good evening.
Excited to be here, excited
for our partnership with Palantir,
and appreciate the opportunity to
come and speak to you all and tell
you a little bit about what we've
been creating at Healthpeak.
Before I get into that, let me tell
you a little about our company.
Healthpeake is a real estate
investment company.
We own and operate over
700 facilities across the United
States, spanning life science,
outpatient medical care.
And seniors housing.
Every day, hundreds of thousands
of people go inside our facilities.
It's nurses, it's patients,
it' researchers.
They're running clinical operations,
they're doing life saving research,
they're delivering patient care.
And our mission at Healthpeak is to
make sure that we're the real estate
partner of choice for all these
healthcare firms.
Probably 18 to 24
months ago, we sat around
at HealthBeak and realized we
had a problem.
We realized that technology wasn't
enhancing what we were doing,
technology was holding us back.
And so we asked ourselves, is there
a way where we could utilize
technology to build the
best real estate investment
management platform and further
our mission to be the real estate
partner of choice?
We quickly realized to do that, we
had to get our employees out from
behind computer screens.
And out in front of our partners and
our tenants.
When we decided where we were gonna
engage with Palantir, we
knew it had to be somewhere where we
could improve a workflow
that would make a real immediate
difference.
And so we chose accounting.
I know accounting isn't the most
exciting workflow
you could choose, but I knew if we
could nail accounting, we could
probably literally do anything.
And so, we decided to dig in.
And it's funny, when we dug in, we
realized it wasn't just our
accountants in corporate offices
doing accounting work.
Accounting was literally taking time
for everybody,
including the people on the front
lines, our property managers.
Our property managers live at the
properties. That's where they do
their day to day.
And instead of being out serving
those clinicians, serving our
tenants, they were stuck behind
computer screens doing accounting.
And so we realized that was
something we had to fix.
We've gone through a lot of
different processes that we've
improved, but I wanna give you one
example of something that
we improved just recently.
Every single month at Healthpeak,
across our 700 properties,
we have thousands of sub-meters
that are generating data for
us, recording how much
energy utilization is going on in
each suite.
And every single month, our property
managers have to take that data,
and they have to go take pictures of
it, and they to upload it into a
spreadsheet, and they do
calculations, they have send it to
accounting, they have comments, it
comes back, it takes hours
and hours of our property manager's
time. It takes them away from our
tenants and puts them behind a
computer screen.
We knew we needed to figure out how
to fix it.
So I want to go just a little behind
the scenes and show you what we
built.
When we ultimately stepped back, we
knew all you really needed to do was
take a picture of a submeter.
And if we could get that submeter
picture and some information,
we could do the whole process
automatically.
We didn't need all these people
doing all these things, sending
spreadsheets back and forth, doing
calculations.
We could have AIP and our ontology
do the entire process,
obviously flagging instances where
there are issues or concerns.
I want to jump into one of them
where we notice an issue.
You can see this is basically just a
picture of a sub-meter, it's a
utility bill, and a lot of
different items that
the AIP is checking regarding
the matching of those two items.
The system knows everything.
It knows how to apply the correct
methodology.
It knows to get the correct dates
and rates.
It calculates the tenant's share of
the expense. It creates the invoice.
It runs it through accounting.
It compares it to historical and
projected amounts.
And ultimately it saves us a ton of
time because instead of a property
manager going through all these
individual items, they're
only looking at the things that were
flagged. So they can get out from
behind the desk and back in front of
our tenants.
That's been super exciting.
We're very excited about what we're
building in accounting, but
honestly, we're more excited about
what were doing in 2026.
This is where I think the platform
can really come to life.
Accounting was a building block.
It provided the foundation of what
we were trying to build, but the
next step is to really create an
operating system that connects
everything in our company.
Our people, our buildings, our data.
And to do that, we knew one of the
things that we would have to do was
GoMobile.
We decided that we needed to build
an app to give our property managers
and our team access to
our ontology and our operating
system wherever they are, whenever
they need it.
I wanna walk you through one example
of something we're building.
Every day across all of our
buildings,
there's thousands and thousands of
interactions happening.
Our tenants are speaking with our
property managers.
They're having conversations about
the quality of the space, about what
they're trying to do.
Sometimes it's complaints.
And we ask ourselves, how do we
capture all of that information?
And so what we have here is
basically our property manager going
into a conversation and
saying, hey, I just talked to the
tenant.
They have a big need.
They need some new people.
They're hiring a lot of people, and
by the way, it's pretty hot in their
office, we might need to adjust the
AC.
At that moment, our property manager
doesn't have to go into some legacy
CRM system, they don't have jotted
down in a notebook, they can
literally just grab their phone,
record a message, and it starts
a chain reaction.
This is what we're excited about.
So at that moment after they record
it, it connects all the dots, and it
not only records the note, it
activates the process.
The first one is to our leasing
team.
We're not waiting for our tenants to
tell us they need more space.
The system is actively monitoring
our ontology, looking for
key instances that could indicate
a tenant and our partners need more
place.
In this case, more employees means
more space, the system
then looks at their current
footprint, it analyzes their growth
pattern, it looks at what's
available in our buildings and
surfaces logical next steps that are
fed to the team.
That they can then go act on.
Second one was for the facilities, a
separate action.
The room was hot, notwithstanding
the thermostat being wrong.
The system can look at the HVAC
history for that suite.
It can identify whether there's been
similar issues in the past, and it
can read the information to
determine the likely root cause and
next step.
For us, that's real leverage.
It's the best people in the best
buildings now supported by a system
that amplifies their impact and the
performance.
Siding part now, we
have the information.
Our engineers diagnose the issues,
we can use our operating system to
create real leverage.
Not only can we look at that unit or
that HVAC unit, we can look at
every maintenance ticket across our
company. We can look energy
consumption data, the age and
warranty status of the equipment.
And critically, cause going back to
the accounting piece, now we can all
the costs we've incurred over time.
We're able to then leverage our
entire scale and start making
capital allocation decisions
informed by operational
intelligence.
We can create a future where every
repair, every maintenance, every
dollar spent across our entire
portfolio can be informed,
and it can help us deploy our
capital better.
The kind of operating model
that we're building toward is
unique.
It's a platform that will learn from
every interaction, and it raises the
performance of everything we're
doing, and ultimately gets back to
our goal of delivering the best
tenant experience for our partners.
Through the automation, the nuance
captured in this one phone call,
this one interaction, generates a
series of activities that they're
acted upon. We're not waiting
anymore for somebody to jot it
down and to make sure it gets done.
One simple conversation driving real
measurable results across the
organization.
As our portfolio grows, we're no
longer limited by the number of
people we have.
We're now just limited by, we're not
even limited by the technology.
We can grow our portfolio without
adding any incremental costs, and
for us, that's very big.
We're excited to have shown
this to you guys today.
We're about the transformation we're
making at HealthBeak.
We have an installation there in the
back. We'd invite you to come join
us and check it out when we're done.
Thank you.
Please welcome Senior Vice President
and Chief Transformation Officer at
Tampa General Hospital,
Dr. Peter Chang.
Good evening, everyone.
Thanks for having me here tonight.
So excited to be here in this
amazing venue.
Thank you, Alex, for putting all of
this together.
Now, let's set the stage of
what healthcare is, at least
for Tampa General.
We are a $4.5 billion organization
in West Central Florida,
so lots of great revenue, but we
operate in the hospital at
around a one to a 1.5%
margin.
So if we have a 2% Medicare cut
this year, Guess what happens
when Medicare is about 40%
of our payer base.
Every year the government has
reductions on what they're
reimbursing healthcare.
Insurance companies are finding
cruel and unusual ways to pay us
less money.
Labor's going up and with
tariffs, supplies and equipment is
going up.
So the only way that we can work
ourselves out of this situation is
to innovate.
And I'll kind of ask a question out
to the audience.
What are the two last industries
to innovate?
I'll give you one, is healthcare.
And the second is education, right?
A teacher will get up in front of a
classroom and teach one way, but
each student may learn in a
different way, and there's no way to
customize how you're gonna teach a
student, and I translate the same
thing over to medicine.
There's no that you could take two
diabetic patients with the same
numbers and treat them exactly
the same way.
So the mantra of pathway-based care.
Is interesting, and I think is
evidence-based, but at the same
point, we need to find a way to
customize care for our patients, and
that's what I'm gonna show you later
today.
So what we have here are the three
big pillars that we look at within
our health system.
We're trying to find the way to
weave together clinical side,
operational side, and finance,
because the finance is so important
to us, and the connective tissue
that weaves through all of that.
Today, we're going to focus in on
the care navigation administrative
view and take you through a
patient journey of a
patient by the name of Jane that
unfortunately got admitted to the
ICU.
Now, if you've ever been in an
hospital before, you realize
that you give
total control away.
That's the number one thing you lose
in a hospital.
And so what you're seeing now is a
live feed. Think about almost like
an ex-feed for a physician.
So as things are happening
throughout the hospital, you're
getting notifications of what's
going on, the information is coming
to find you versus me having
to go back into our EMR and check on
data.
So Jane's had a CT of her
chest, a CAT scan, she's had blood
cultures, she's diagnosed with
sepsis.
Oh, by the way, we use a Palantir
algorithm to pick sepsus up
earlier and get a patient on a
treatment pathway.
What does it result in?
Is a 68% reduction
in 48-hour mortality.
So within two days, is this patient
still with us or not?
In the last two years, that's
resulted in 700 additional patients
being able to leave the hospital
versus how we operated before.
Hospitals around the country get
sepsis right about 20 to 30%
of the time.
So how would you like to be a
patient walking into that scenario?
So in this example, we're actually
walking through where a
pulmonology clearance is given,
a ID clearance is giving.
The patient meets downgrade criteria
out of the ICU because they've
responded well to the antibiotics.
We know that by the feed over on
the side and the patient's
getting ready to move on to the next
stage of the care.
You have an AIP
reader that's looking over the notes
and actually suggesting the next
best pathway, which is to
downgrade the patient from the ICU.
As we start moving on.
We'll make the recommendation that
now the patient can be downgraded
out of the ICU, but we have a
problem here because now the
patients still needs IV antibiotics
and that IV antibiotic course
is gonna be an additional four days
in the hospital outside of
the ICU.
So it adds an additional 4 days to
our length of stay, taking a bed
away from another patient.
Luckily, we have AIP
reading the chart and recommending
hospital at home.
So what that is, is the ability to
take the hospital-based care and
actually take it out and mobilize it
to the patient's home and
get the patient moving out of the
hospital. So it's running an
eligibility in the background that
says consider hospital at home.
So as a physician, I don't need to
remember does this patient live
close enough to the hospital?
What is their payer?
Because only certain payers cover
hospital at home at this point in
time. And then again, being able
to enroll that patient into
the hospital at-home program easily.
So I can go ahead and look at my
criteria.
I can see my milestones have been
met for IV antibiotics,
downgrade out of the ICU, where the
patient lives, what their payer is,
and I'm moving on to the next
step, which is getting this patient
enrolled into the Hospital at Home
program.
So as that happens, you'll
see AIP is helping out,
create the referral order, get that
placed out to that team so they can
get ready to enroll that patient
next into the system.
As you move on here, this gives
the patient view of the pain
of all the
little things that happen during
an admission, a lab result, an
imaging result, diagnostics,
infusions, nursing orders,
a procedure.
And imagine being able, the dream
is, if we reach such a
high level of automation, could
we get to the point where we have a
digital screen at the foot of the
bed actually delivering a message
to the patient saying between the
hours of 9 and 10.
Your physician will be by to round.
Between the hours of 11 to 12,
you're gonna get a CAT scan, the
result will be back in the
afternoon, and your physician will
be be back to discuss the results.
First is sitting in the bed and
looking at this clock that I'm
looking at right now, it's like the
24 o'clock second by second,
drifting away as you're sitting in
a bed wondering what's going to
happen to me next.
Now the most exciting piece for this
is this is underway right
now. We're about halfway through the
build. The proof of concept of all
the pieces that got us to where we
are right now have all been
successful, but this is just such
a small slice of the patient care
journey from an inpatient
perspective.
The dream of this is being able to
apply it outside the walls of the
hospital.
So how can I take a breast cancer
patient that's going to need
an MRI, a PET
scan, a port,
radiation oncology consult,
a chair time in chemotherapy, and a
surgical consult?
And be able to plan around the
patient's life.
That's a mom.
She maybe has to pick up her kids.
We don't ask her like, hey, what are
you doing? We say, oh, we have an
appointment at 2.30.
And in her head, she's thinking,
that's the time I need to pick my
kids. Who's going to pick out my
kids if I have to come and get a
treatment?
So really being able to take this
operational concept, the clinical
flow, and get patient from,
okay, we're unfortunately diagnosing
you with a cancer to the point where
I have.
You in a treatment pathway in a
shorter period of time, resulting
in hopefully a better outcome and
a happier patient.
It's been such a pleasure to share a
little bit about our healthcare
journey at Tampa General with you
all tonight.
Big thanks to David Yu.
David is our Palantir FDSE,
who really helps us with all of our
engineering activities and it's
such a big part, as Alex talked
about, that person that gets to
know your organization is like
nothing else, and it becomes more
of a friendship.
Versus a vendor-client
relationship.
So thanks again, and it's a great
time talking to you tonight.
Please welcome Senior Director
Commercial Growth and PMO
Lead at Johnson Controls,
Gabriel Dornbach.
Good evening, everyone.
My name is Gabriel Dombach, and I
lead the growth commercial
PMO for Johnson Controls
in EMEA.
I'm joining you today from beautiful
Switzerland.
And I want to show you how we are
reshaping our 140-year-old
company.
So we are a world
leader for smart buildings.
That means that we create safe,
healthy, and sustainable places.
And our customers are commercial
and industrial,
building owners and operators.
Think of offices, hotels,
data centers, schools,
universities, and airports.
And many of those are truly mission
critical to society.
And actually, because of this
pretty iconic location here,
we are also a key supplier to the US
Navy. So we provide a truck, fire,
and security solutions to ships like
this. It also happens
that we have the world's
largest Largest portfolio in
building technologies and
with that comes a lot of complexity
So what you see in the back end is
our enterprise operating system.
You can see that the agent is
running is Mapping
data is adding
location IDs together with assets
another agent is crafting a
value proposition for that specific
asset and this
automation of our lifecycle covers
literally everything from production
to installation to maintenance and
The actual power of this is
automation first.
So we actually re-imagine
the way we do the process so that
it adapts to automation first,
and what you see on top is the
key metrics that we care about,
and they're actually very simple.
The first one is the dollar value we
generate with this.
The second one, and that is a
crucial one for us, it's the
conversion rate from lead to
opportunity, and it really shows the
quality.
And the effectiveness of everything
we do.
The third one is the number of leads
you can see.
So it's 180,000, but actually
that's a two-folded numbers.
So one thing we do is we create
leads looking into the history,
interactions with our customers that
have not happened.
But the second thing we is we
actually create leads looking into
future.
So in other words, what we have here
is the key to
build the future pipeline for
our salespeople.
And in only 18 months,
we have actually increased with this
project our lead-to-opportunity
conversion rate by 5x.
And now I want to show you how we
have digitalized the lifecycle.
So it all starts with mapping the
data. You see about 200 data
sources, ERPs,
service tools, SaaS tools.
It all comes into one place.
We have the entire region mapped
out. And the reason why we do this
is because we need to make the data
visible to make it accessible and
then usable.
We dive into it, and what you see is
the accessible part of the data.
So we have our deployed items, our
customer contracts.
We have addresses, locations, LNMs.
It's all there. And on the far
right, you have the agents, which
are grabbing the clean, structured
data, and they use that to
automate the process.
Now, how do we identify those leads?
On the left, you see that we
take all our product lifecycle
knowledge and we code it into
Foundry.
So we have an example here of a fire
panel that has no maintenance
contract. So there is an upsell
opportunity.
We can ask also Foundry questions
like, show me the customers that
have smoke detectors which are
obsolete because we want to replace
them. I can ask Foundry,
make me a campaign of all
the customers that have a license,
a software license which needs an
upgrade so I can sell them an
upgrade.
And we also partner with our
salespeople.
And that's actually really crucial,
because if you think of our sales
people, they have 20, 30, 40 years
of experience.
At some point, they leave the
company, they retire, they change
positions.
And we take all that knowledge
and we make actionable rules out of
it.
And that is actually critical
to us, because this tribal knowledge
is this way preserved
and we can leverage across the
entire organization.
What is even more powerful is
because we can decide the type of
leads. We want our sales people to
focus on.
We tell the system, focus
on deals with a higher margins.
Or we can tell the systems, focus on
deals that have more
volume.
And we can predict for every single
lead, the individual
customer conversion rate.
That's like a remote control
for your business, because you steer
the business into the direction you
want to.
And through that engine, we have
encoded over 100,000 leads
at this point.
Now, if I dive into one lead, I can
see that AIP has already mapped
out the seven steps fully
automatically.
It has mapped the individual asset.
It has understood the customer
journey. It makes sense of some kind
of physical evidence.
A service technician that was on
site took pictures.
The pictures go into the ontology.
Again, this circular process is
starting. The data is being reused.
And AIP has now generated as
individual value proposition.
And we want to ship that lead to
a seller.
But AIP is pausing and is
asking a human operator to
interact.
Because AIP understood that it's
a specific customer situation where
we have one customer with two
buildings.
In one building, we have a chiller
with a maintenance contract.
In the next building, we have
security device.
There is no maintenance contract, so
now AIP's giving the
human operator the chance to say,
Hey. Don't do you want to give him
a special condition a special offer?
So that actually this second device
that has no maintenance contract
will be in packaged in the
first maintenance contract It's
better for the business.
It's bad for the customer.
The operator takes the information
keys it in and sends it
out The system
will select the best sales channel
to execute the lead account
managers Inside sales service
technicians and every technician
is becoming a trusted advisor
for our customers.
So They do not just longer
maintain equipment.
They are actually now proactive.
They are predictive.
So they come to the customer and
say, hey, Mr. Customer.
I'm here for my routine maintenance.
But actually, my app is showing me
that your building is in critical
conditions because of a couple of
assets. Let me walk you through
that.
That's the type of conversation we
want to have with our customers.
It is really exciting to see that
once you have all this data mapped
out, there's really no
limit to anything, okay?
So we have deployed this
same human AI
partnering across the entire
organization now.
We are doing it in procurement.
We have AIP that is
scanning spanning patterns and
servicing cost opportunities,
cost saving opportunities throughout
the organization.
We are picking those opportunities
and we are.
Driving them into an automated RFQ
workflow end to end.
And it is really incredible to see
that you can transform
a 140-year-old company
with the power of AI.
Please welcome, from R1,
Executive Vice President and Chief
Product Officer Steve Albert,
and Senior Vice President
Engineering R37
John Katzer.
Hey, everybody, I'm Steve, this is
John.
We're from R1.
And it was very nice of Peter to tee
up earlier the challenge that health
systems have, especially from a
margin perspective.
Stepping back even further, in the
U.S., the health systems
spend $740
billion across
all the systems just to collect
the reimbursement that they're owed
for the care they provide patients.
That's an office and administrative
burden.
It's manual processes, it's
paperwork, it phone calls, it's
handing off work from
team to team.
And that can cost almost 4%
of the revenue that they pull in.
Compared to other industries, it's
one of the highest percentages
that there is.
So we at R1, we're in the middle of
this problem.
We serve health systems.
We have over 500 clients.
We serve 95 of the top 100
health systems and help them to
address this problem.
We've been doing this for 20 years.
For eight of those clients, we run
their entire revenue cycle.
And for the rest of those client, we
provide them, on average, about four
solutions.
And over those 20 years, we've
developed a tremendous amount of
intelligence.
Best practice processes, rules
engines, and with
the AI revolution that's happening,
at the beginning of this year, we
decided we needed to take a
fundamentally different approach,
and we've been embedding that
intelligence in what we call a
revenue operating system.
We call it Fair OS.
The revenue operating system is
aimed at comprehensively automating
complex processes to accelerate
reimbursement and to make it as
accurate as possible.
And importantly, it's an
interconnected system that is aimed
not just at resolving problems but
preventing them in the first place.
Oh, OK.
So denials represent a
huge administrative burden in health
care.
We know at R1 that 9%
of claims will be
first pass denied.
After weeks of administrative back
and forth, phone calls,
gathering evidence, clinicians going
back and fourth, you'll end up with
only a small fraction will actually
stay denied.
And so to address that
administrative burden, We've built
the Fair OS, Revenue Cycle
Operating System.
It's completely agentic.
The system starts with the
triage and orchestration agent that
takes in all the data that
a payer provides, the clinical
records, combine it, and
routes any
potential denial to a specialized
agent that knows how to address
and solve that problem.
Could be
an eligibility auth denial,
and that agent.
Is the specialist that knows how to
go through and solve it.
Let's look at an example of a
completed denial that was processed.
Here's the complete account where
the pair requested additional
information.
The triage agent received
information and routed to
specialized, lax information.
The agent got to work, reading the
medical record, looking at the
denial which explained
what information was needed, looking
through the ontology and identifying
all the information the pair needs.
The agent then gathered the required
documentation together into a
cohesive packet ready to send
and actually sent it to the pair.
Automatically.
Completely automatically.
In this case, this is completely
resolved without human intervention
at all.
This is a process that would
typically take about 20 to 40
minutes for a person to just look
through everything, try to
understand what's going on, and
collect the packet and send it
through.
This agent orchestration.
The right agent working on the right
problem at the right time.
Next, let's take a look at an
in-progress case requiring an
appeal.
In this case, the triage agent
identified the
denial and routed it to an appeals
agent, which gathers clinical
documentation, research the
payer's denial rationale, and
drafts an appeal letter.
Here's where human-AI collaboration
becomes critical.
Appeals require clinical judgment,
so the agent surfaces a
recommendation for a specialist to
review and refine.
It's not replacing humans,
it empowers them.
The agent handles the tedious work
of gathering all this data so
the specialist can focus on the
high-value decision.
It's a model we believe translates
across industries.
AI handles volumes and the
complexity of big data, and humans
provide judgment and expertise.
Zooming out, these are all examples
of just one workflow each,
but behind this is a system of
agents that constantly are working
in parallel across thousands of
accounts, each managed by an
appropriate agent, with human
oversight where it matters most.
What makes this all possible is the
unified ontology connecting clinical
data, claims data, payer
rules and appeals history together
along with the final outcome.
So an agent's handoff work, they
pass the full context.
The triage agent makes sure the lax
info agent sees what's been tried
before, what documentation
was submitted and what the payer
requires.
And critically, every decision,
every action that got taken by
humans and AI
and all the decision and final
outcome makes it back to the
ontology.
So our agents get smarter over time.
So you can imagine a lax info agent
learning what works for
specific payers, denial types,
and hospital systems.
Great, so John showed you
it's great that the system can
autonomously resolve problems or
denials when they happen, but I
mentioned it's an interconnected
system and it's even better to
prevent the problems from happening
in the first place.
So what you're seeing now is the
denial prevention part of the fair
operating system.
So this is where we have agents that
are monitoring payer policy changes
and they're also monitoring denial
trends and actual payer behaviors
from denials that we've seen in
the past.
An agent had made
a recommendation, has come up with
an idea for some logic that
should be implemented to prevent
denials on claims going out in the
future.
It came up with a back test.
It actually looked at claims that
had been previously submitted and
estimated that we
could resolve almost all
of the denials. We could prevent
them from happening in the first
place and it would reduce the amount
of work by about 75% and accelerate
the time to payment by
about two X.
This is like a look behind the
scenes, but it did this with full
access to the ontology and all the
tools that are available, and it
actually wrote all the Python code
that can
be implemented into production.
We have a human in the loop looking
at this right now just for
validation, but over time as we get
more confident, we can imagine this
being fully agentic.
So hopefully that gives you a sense
of what we're building here.
You know, we view ourselves at R1
that we've been pioneering revenue
cycle technology for a
long time, workflow,
rules engines, machine learning.
Robotic process automation, but to
us, this is the most excited we've
ever been because this can achieve
a vision of comprehensive automation
with AI that we think can really
benefit and lower the cost of
administrative costs for the entire
system that can benefit not just our
customers, providers, but also
for payers and patients.
Thanks a lot.
Please welcome A.I.
Lead at Thompson-Kavanaugh
construction, Joe Petra.
Hi everyone, my name is Joe Patra.
I lead the Foundry Development Team
at Cavanaugh Construction.
We're a vertically integrated, heavy
civil construction company in
Ottawa, Canada.
We build roads, sewers,
subdivisions, homes.
We produce our own asphalt,
aggregates and concrete.
We run hundreds of pieces of heavy
equipment and trucks every day.
I'm just so excited to get to share
with you guys our unique approach
to Palantir Foundry.
As the company grew over 70 years,
so did our systems.
Each solving a problem.
But together created an even bigger
one, complexity.
We were bending our business to work
with off-the-shelf software and
feeling this economy is a scale to
come with it.
We needed a change.
Enter Palantir.
So as we began our Foundry journey,
every system we connected to
highlighted the same thing.
This doesn't work the way our
business works and it would be so
much easier if we just built it in
Foundry.
So we started asking the question,
why don't we just build it in
foundry?
So long story short, we've gone
all in.
So much so that every other software
must justify its existence.
And so far, they haven't been able
to.
97% of our employees use Foundry
every day.
Foundry is our operating system.
So what does this look like?
We picked a few simple examples to
demonstrate how information flows
through the ontology, workflow to
workflow, powering our day-to-day
operations.
Here you can see our homepage.
We've named the system Total
Operations Management, or TOM,
to honor the company's founder, Tom
Kavanaugh.
We'll navigate here to global
schedule.
This is our scheduling tool that's
replaced everything else.
P6, Microsoft project,
spreadsheets, all of it.
You can imagine keeping all those
previous tools in sync was a ton of
work, and of course, led to errors.
Now we have one plan, one
schedule, one source of truth
for all our operations in one place.
Moving activity, and every team
knows instantly.
And what looks like just a simple
puck on the screen.
Is actually packed with information
underneath.
Contract items, production rates,
mixed designs, trucking requirements
and budgets, all because of the
underlying ontology.
I was a scheduler for six years,
and no one has successfully run
operations from a critical path
schedule, but we've solved it.
For the first time, the information
flows to the field, and the field
executes on the same information.
We have Kavanaugh Connect.
This is our OSDK app published in
the app stores powered by Foundry.
You can see we've got a simple
newsfeed.
We can now reach every employee
wherever they are.
You can imagine this is extremely
powerful.
Next, you can see an example of an
employee submitting a timecard.
All employees now have access to the
newsfeed, timecards,
support from HR, payroll and IT
right in their phone, in their
pocket.
And just six months ago, this
was all done on paper.
As thousands of pieces of paper
handled every pay period.
Foundry saved us hours and hours,
eliminating the handling and
administration of those paper
timecards.
Site 360.
This is a Foundry mobile workshop
that's replaced our legacy
field time capture app.
This is where the Foreman's Day
comes together.
Time cards land here automatically
from Kavanaugh Connect.
Foreman manage production, labor,
approve equipment, order trucks,
manage their crews, all from their
phones.
And because the planned data flows
to them, they only have to fill in
the gaps.
What used to take hours, now only
takes 10 minutes because the work
and the data move as one through
the ontology.
This is Site 360 Manager.
This is where all the field
information flows back into the
office.
Daily reports, production, labor,
equipment, costing, all in one place
for managers to review and approve
in real time.
Whether it's our mobile app, Site
360, or global schedule, we're
meeting the users where they are.
Again, these workflows are simple,
and that's the point.
By eliminating the third-party
software we used to use, we've
removed so much complexity from our
business.
No more paper, no more
silos.
And as we zoom out, you start to see
the real breadth of our system.
These tiles represent the tools we
use to run our operations every day.
From the contracts that define the
work, to the resources we perform
that work with, labor, equipment,
materials, they're all managed
inside Foundry, meaning they're
fully connected.
And when we say one operating
system, it doesn't mean we're
forcing our users to conform.
It's the opposite.
Foundry gives us the flexibility to
build the way we want, empowering
our operations.
And finally, the engine that powers
it all, the ontology.
It looks complicated, but in
reality, it's just big.
It's big because it's the digital
representation of our business.
Every employee, every truck,
every piece of equipment, every job
is in here.
You can imagine how hard this was to
maintain with our legacy siloed
systems.
Every line you see here represents
what used to be a phone call, an
email, a text, or someone
driving paper around a job site.
Historically, collecting this data
was hard work, unfairly punishing
operations.
But when you build this way,
collecting the data stops being work
and becomes an output we call
for free, just by doing the
job.
And what you're looking at on the
screen is our data, on the left,
objects in the middle, and workshops
on the right.
The ontology is the secret weapon.
Nothing else comes close.
And not only are we getting rid of
third-party software, we're actually
eclipsing their development.
We've replaced their functionality
and then beaten them to new features
all within the year because
of the ontology.
We're honored to show publicly for
the first time, AIP Analyst.
We're now able to ask plain language
questions about our business, and
have AI reason through the ontology
to find the answers.
We're already making real-time
decisions on information that was
previously incredibly difficult
to get, and took ages to
compile.
I'm asking analysts a simple
question about our fleet, which
vehicle requires my attention.
This isn't a demo, this is our real
data.
And you'll see analysts finds the
truck objects, the inspection
logs, the maintenance records,
even fault codes, all by following
the relationships in the ontology.
And so, it comes back with eight
trucks in repair, three with
active faults, and it appears some
license are out of date.
So six months ago, this would have
taken ages to compile.
But because of the ontology and AIP
analysts, we know in minutes.
And so, while I know these licenses
aren't out of data, I asked our
fleet manager.
What it's actually telling us is we
haven't updated this information.
Highlighting something really,
really cool about Foundry.
You don't have to wait until your
data is clean to use Foundry,
use Foundary to clean your data.
So, in closing, we've gone from
paper to Palantir in just under 12
months by replacing disconnected
systems with Foundry.
Today, real operations run end
to end through the ontology, which
is why we're seeing the emergence of
AI in our operations.
We are gonna be the first
construction company to have true
operational AI.
We didn't just bring Foundry into
our business, we put our business
in Foundry, and we're gonna prove
that you can run your business with
nothing but.
We're planning for the long term.
We're excited to announce that we're
partnering with Palantir to
commercialize these solutions across
the industry.
Together with Palatir, we're raising
the ceiling for construction and
with it the floor.
The fastest route to operational AI
is to run your business through it.
Go all in.
Thank you so much for your time.
Please welcome Head of Corporate
Development at Palantir,
Sasha Spivak.
Another round of applause for our
speakers.
I wanna talk a little bit about one
of the biggest things I've learned
at Palantir over the last 10
years, which is trust.
I have a mechanical engineering
background and was hired as a
writer, a job I was absolutely
unqualified for.
In fact, in my hiring thesis, it
quite literally said weaknesses.
When I landed and was doing
the job that I was obviously never
going to be good at,
I got my first dose of what
it means to trust.
I had to trust that the
team, and specifically the person
who took a bet on me, saw
something. I had trust that they
believed that I would see something.
Many years later, when we were going
public, and I took a moment
to reflect on the
gravity of the thing that I got to
be working on, and the.
People that I was doing that
with.
And I had another realization.
I said, excuse my language,
who fucked up and trusted me
with what I'm currently doing and
who I'm doing it with?
And that was sort of my second
lesson in trust.
It was like no one fucked up.
They trusted me, and so I had
to trust them.
And then later came a third form of
trust, the kind where
Alex frequently has these ideas
where you just have to believe
until you see that they come true
every single time, like his most
recent one, which was we have
to hire kids out of high school who
when they look at a college campus,
see a woke education, an unsafe
place to be, and you
just to have to.
And instead of just going with it,
you have to commit to it until you
manifest that reality into
existence.
And today, I'm
reminded of the fourth form
of trust, which is being with all of
you in this room. And that's the
trust of being with family.
We ask you to trust us
with really unbearably high
missions.
And we trust you with
those as well.
I feel very grateful, very humbled,
very proud to be in a room with
people that we trust
implicitly and it is incredible to
be trusted with the same thing.